shut up a minute
give me the word
order order
I say to the unknown gentleman give me issues
I will not tolerate such behavior
if you wanna go out go out now
but if you stand again I will load you out
make your mind up and shut up and get out
connecting straw testing
currently going to shut up a minute
just simply walk
I now warn of the honorable members
that if they persist
in refusing to comply with my order
to withdraw
I shall be content
compelled to name both of them
which may lead to them being suspended
from the house right
mister speaker
may I welcome the new cabinet to their places
we have a new chancellor
accepted a job from the prime minister
on Wednesday afternoon
and then told him to quit on Thursday morning
and you and you
northern ireland secretary
who once asked
if you need a passport to get to dairy
and the new education secretary
whose union ministers have literally
been giving the middle finger to the public
it is truly the country's loss
that they will only be in post for a few weeks
Mr Speaker
the tory leadership contest
is quickly descending into toxic race
to the right
and it's clear that whoever wins that race
scotland loses
the former chancellor has pledged to govern
like margaret thatcher
the current chancellor is threatening
20% cuts to the nhs and public services
and they're all trying to outdo each other
on an extreme brexit
costing the economy billions
is the real reason
that the prime minister won't endorse
any of these awful candidates
because whoever becomes the next total leader
will make genghis khan look like a moderate